joining us now other former England star
John Barnes and the deputy chief
executive the professional footballers
Association
Bobby Barnes welcome to you both John I
would start with you John and to what
extent you think will football has been
looking forward to getting back to
training I mean I you know you know far
better than most of us how onerous a
regime is it I mean it's presumably
pretty tough yes but of course there are
many different aspects to football
training of course you can easily get
back to training and social assistance
obviously not playing five outside or
eleven aside but they're shooting joe
says dribbling drills just passing to us
in fact the majority of football is done
where am i you don't have to be right
next to the other player so suppose from
that respect I think it's a very safe
thing to do because you are able to
you're able to control the distances
between players so I don't think getting
back to training is that much of an
issue
yeah Bobby Barnes out how long did you
estimate it's necessary for players to
to reach a pitch of fitness that would
allow them to compete at a level at
which they were competing before
coronavirus well well obviously there's
been quite we're coming up now for two
two and a half months since players were
actually in action but I think it's
important to bear in mind that whilst
today is a very significant step on the
road towards getting back to Premier
League football this is indeed just the
first step and we as an industry it's
something that we certainly won't be
looking to do to push the issue I think
it's important that we take small steps
both to build confidence and to build
Fitness because we still have a way to
go i mean obviously the the projected
time for the games to commence was
generally considered to be around about
the 12th of June I think that's probably
unlikely now because I think we are
going to need a few weeks in addition to
that to actually get the players back
fit now because obviously this being
just the first non-contact
part of the game we still have to go to
step two and there still is a lot of
work to be done before we get to step
two in terms of they actually get into
contact training before we can actually
then start to consider the step of
actually playing game so yeah this is a
first step on a long road yeah I think
I'm only saying John Barnes said the
Bundesliga they were five to five weeks
from the beginning of training
the resumption of actual matches though
though of course behind closed doors as
well just just on the point about how
the players feel about all this in our
introduction we talked about some of
them having misgivings about the safety
not just for themselves but family
members as well do you have any sense
from your conversations with people
still in football of how the players are
feeling right now I mean everybody has
an opinion in the same industry some may
say you know I would like to get back to
work some ones and footballers are no
different you know some footballers say
yes I would mind going back now and
reservations as to whether they feel
they can be played in the near future so
there is no right or wrong as
individuals you decide whether you think
a from a risk point of view it's worth
doing or not I don't think there's
necessarily a homogenous or altogether
attitude towards whether we should all
play or not so you know like normal
human being some will some will say
let's get back quicker than others
that's just a way you know like it's a
Bobby I'm guessing you're having to
answer queries from from footballers
themselves who want to be sure that what
can be done is done I mean suggestions
for instance that there's cleaning going
on of footballs of cones even playing
surfaces everything is being done hello
people
Bobby I hope you can still hear me I was
making the point that if your members
are saying to you we need to be
absolutely sure that it's safe to go
back we're hearing reports that
everything is being done particularly
apropos cleaning reports suggesting
footballs been cleaned cones been
cleaned even playing surfaces being
cleaned well yes the without doubt the
primarily together with the government
has put together a comprehensive return
to training protocol which does indeed
cover all of the areas that you've
mentioned there the intention is
certainly there within the Premier
League to ensure that the the safest
possible environment can be made
available to the players to actually
return to training and then hopefully at
some time in the future return to
playing and you have to take into
account however that very there is
indeed a a wide spread of opinion and
very legitimate concern because as you
sit at the top of the show there are
players who have individual
circumstances which will directly impact
on both their inter inclination and
ability to get back to training we have
players obviously who have pregnant
partners those with their young children
we have
oh no Bobby we're just having some
problems with with your leg let's go
back to John Barnes to reflect John on
your I think your opinion that actually
neutral stadiums I mean almost the
training of Pro you to the resumption of
the 2019 to 2020 season to some degree
when it comes to playing matches
top-flight matches neutral stadiums have
seen Bundesliga there with empty
stadiums what's your sense of how it's
gonna play out well that's the where
there's gonna be lead shot stadiums or
just your home stadiums I don't see the
playing matches at home as long as
obviously you know the fans recognize
and understand that in this time they're
not able to go to the stadiums then I
don't see the point maybe they're trying
to talk about playing neutral stadiums
because if it's a long way away from you
stay in your home for more example but I
think it's up to us as human beings
and as members of society to have a bit
of a responsibility that even if the
stadium's two miles from us we're not
allowed to go so I wouldn't I would be
against playing in in your own stadium
but behind closed doors as they've done
in Germany so I don't think it's a
necessity for human I'm sorry for finito
stadiums but I do understand that if you
want to get back quicker you probably
will have to play behind closed doors
which isn't ideal
but nevertheless this is not an ideal
circumstance you know we have to make
them out of a bad situation so playing
in empty stadiums for me if we decide
that sooner rather than later we have to
get back to play I don't see that as a
problem and John just just been
obviously as a former you know Liverpool
player yourself I mean if Liverpool are
crowned champions you would expect to
see relegation happen as well what why
is that linkage necessary it's about the
integrity of the competition Liverpool
winning and not having promotion and
relegation I'm not a storm allegation
I'm talking about Leeds and West Brom
and crew in leak two or whatever coming
up you can't just arbitrarily
it's like saying well give leaves the
championship why just give Liverpool one
I'm going to leave the championship or
cruise they're top of league what it's
about honoring the competition it's not
just about Liverpool getting the
championship but forgetting everything
else it's about for me the integrity of
this of the competition not necessarily
just the score of the football but
competition that's why I'm perplexed to
find out why in Scotland they gave
Celtic the championship and relegated
hearts
but we just you know PFA is the trade
union of professional footballers how
worried are you that this this hiatus
when people who love football haven't
had access to it might might perhaps
teach some of them that they they can
live without it after all well I think
it's fair to say that we don't have a
divine right that football is the number
one sport in this country it's something
that we obviously have to work very hard
to preserve and to cherish I think that
what you are seeing now the steps that
are being taken highlight really the
impact and the emotional attachment that
people do have to this a national sport
I think were we not the number one sport
not just in this country in the world I
don't think we'd be taking the measure
that we are to actually get back to some
degree of normality because certainly
people do want their Fixer football back
as soon as they possibly can and I'm
sure that those of us who were able to
tune in to the Bundesliga on on the
weekend work we're doing that very much
in the mind that football in any shape
or form we want to get back and
obviously we're going to have to take
steps to try and get the game back as
John said earlier and I echo that view I
think it's not ideal to have empty
stadia but at the same time if that's
the only way we can actually get
football back and that's what we've got
to embrace and try and try and move
forward with without doubt we're going
to see real differences it's going to be
a different experience but at the same
time we do have to do as much as we can
to try and establish that games and
competitions can be finished on the
field and not in boardrooms and
certainly keeping the integrity of the
games by actually if possible getting 11
against 11 or Saturday afternoon I think
that should be our goal or across the
border Bobby Barnes John Barnes thanks
very much indeed thanks a lot thank you